les véhicules à essence et un diesel se
retrouve dans le viseur de la coque des
[Musique]
représentants britanniques du transport
exhorte les gouvernements et les
constructeurs à s'engager à mettre fin à
la vente des véhicules polluants d'ici
2040 une trentaine de pays ont signé
cette entente dont le canada le mexique
et le royaume uni en revanche la chine
les etats unis la france et l'allemagne
parmi les plus importants pays
constructeurs ont refusé de le faire ne
soit pas de voir des pays qui comptent
sur les grands manufacturiers
automobiles pour leur économie se plie
aux hobbies berra temps autour de ces
compagnies là six constructeurs
automobiles s'engagent à vendre
uniquement des véhicules zéro émission
d'ici 2040 il s'agit de ford volvo jihem
mercedes benz jaguar land rover et la
chinoise billets 10 mai défi de taille
pour ces constructeurs qui devront
revoir de fond en comble leur chaîne de
production afin de construire uniquement
des véhicules électriques faudra voir
maintenant comment les constructeurs
pourront entrer le défi qui sera lié
d'abord au prix et à l'accessibilité de
ces véhicules
nous avons besoin de mesures incitatives
clame la dirigeante de ford qui demande
au gouvernement un coup de pouce
financier afin de réduire les coûts de
construction et rendre les billets que
électrique abordable la suppression des
véhicules à moteur pourrait avoir un
effet considérable sur l'environnement
alors que le transport routier
représente plus de 10% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sur la planète ici
giron bergeron radio canada montréal